to go off of what um ice cream right
what you said about how your old school
and you um just I can't remember
everything you said but what you just
said about being old school a lot of
women have taken that mindset in the
role like I need to do this for myself I
need to provide I need to be the
masculine so that that essence of being
old school wanting to be feminine
wanting to just be a woman in a sense is
very slim to none and a lot a woman and
it's not until late that they realize
hmm maybe I should retract how I've been
acting in the masculine way to be able
to attract what I want and then there's
some that's like no why would I why
would I lower myself to attract a man
when a man needs to be XYZ to be able to
attract me I think a wife's a wife
before she's a wife
do you understand I agree so there's
certain characteristics you can't meet
somebody and then when they then you
show them who you are because then
they're not going to make you a wife
when a man like you said what you bring
to the table
um I do think the women are at the table
if a man reads meets the right woman she
will add value to that man that's
non-tangible and that's just that on
that that's what I believe what value
value to a man that's non-tangible that
means he will become ten times more
valuable than he was before he met him
his characteristics the way he is
certain things that make him a great man
money isn't the only thing that makes
him a great man the right woman makes
you want to do better be better create a
family create a legacy build and create
together that's what I think I think
that's a narrative that we've sold women
to make us feel like we're more valuable
than we are like for example I think
most billionaires that even if they've
been married with their wife for 20 30
years they seem like good women and they
get a divorce like they're usually fine
after they're still doing great things
Jeff Bezos
um same with Microsoft guy like I don't
I don't think I think men are great and
if like a great man's gonna be a great
man regardless if he has a woman or not
it depends on what is Genghis Khan I
think would still conquered the world
even if he didn't have a Mane I don't
know what Einstein either still done
what he was doing
I didn't say that they wouldn't I just
said if you have the right woman beside
you you're even better that's what I
think well I think sure like I think
it's better to have the right woman but
I don't I don't think they really play a
part in a man's success not not really I
do like I think I think that like hard
working like I'll my dad even though my
mom like helped him build his business
and she did help a lot
um I would still say he would have done
the same thing even without her okay
like because the woman helps navigate a
man's thought process and certain things
if he listens to her as well certain
times that's just me I feel like the man
is the head the woman is the neck and I
feel like there are certain things that
a woman can see in hindsight sometimes
that a man can't see he's more logical
she's more emotional and stuff but I
feel like she instills certain things in
him that he doesn't have and when when
you have the right woman that can help
you to grow with you and build with you
you'll be more of a principal person
more of a principal person listen bro I
just think like this year there is a
certain level of synergy that that is uh
good between you know when you're in a
relationship when you're when you're
with a good woman but the woman doesn't
necessarily make him a better man he is
what he is
see what I'm saying so I I just I just
don't agree with that at all and then
you said and then also you said the
woman then you also said the woman is
the table how did you come to that
that's what I believe yeah but I just
feel like a woman basically a man will
can become even more greater with a
woman beside him so how does that make
her the table I think if you'd like
specifically describe it like how like a
woman is the person you know like they
say like you give her a house and she
creates a home you give her food she
creates a dinner plate you plant the
seeds she gives you a child she's able
to create things out of whatever you
give her you understand what I'm saying
no she's a support she's not a table
she's that's my opinion it's just no I
feel you you cannot think that there is
any you know you can say what you think
that's just my business what would make
more sense is that you you work together
I think what you're saying sounds more
like your two pieces of the same of a
pie in it like your two sides of a pie
but when you say it's the table it kind
of sounds like the woman is the Bo end
or the guy's just the The Cameo
character Brothers he does when you say
the table because the table is the the
epicenter of the of everything in that
in that um scenario in that situation
yeah that's where the dinner's on there
we're the ones that have the babies and
everything I just feel like we are the
table
where the table you probably bought the
guy brings the chairs he brings
everything to us
he probably bought and built the table
you bought the house he's protecting you
what are you talking about like I mean
like the man built the house and sure
you can add decorations and make it at
home he built the house
like what what can I mean isn't about
food isn't Just About Furniture why
can't what can a man get from a woman
that's why so much people broke up when
it was locked down what they couldn't
live in the house together what kind of
my houses went homes what can a man get
from a woman that he can't get from a
cook a maid and a hooker
I don't just think it says clean cut I
don't think it's as as clean cut as that
I just want to cook I just want to do
you understand what I'm saying because
there's energy there there's chemistry
there there's a relationship there yeah
no no no I don't I don't know you just
think that a man would just just get a
cook just get a cleaner yeah there's
plenty of them yeah and that's okay I
don't know if that's what I'm not saying
that's okay just saying like if that's
that what does a woman offer like I'm
saying that the men are on the table I
don't think the women are the table I
think the men are the table and the
women can come along
for the ride and they can either come or
they can most women don't want to be The
Driver they want to be in the sidecar
breath you know what I'm saying they
want to be in a nice ride they don't
want to be The Driver they don't want to
buy the car and drive the car they want
to be riding shotgun bro how can you be
the table from the sidecar how can you
be the leader from the sidecar you can't
broth like like you don't even protect
the site like I think
I can understand what you're saying
isn't not the table in the aspect as we
know what the table is how females say
oh on the table I bring everything but
it's more of looking at what does what
is the aspect of a table it's a support
so if
say you needed to step on it to do
something better that she's there to
support him she's like she's able to
support
you put so the aspect of a table is to
support whatever you put on it and so if
a man needs to elevate whatever a
woman's there to support him a woman's
there to support whatever is placed
there uh like she said building a family
building
um a home XYZ she's there to support him
in his aspects is that kind of what you
were talking about with the table I kind
of understand it I don't I don't agree
with you if you're more like the food on
the table that's what I said because the
the table without the table there which
is the the origin without the table
there the foundation is you can't you
can't put no food on air
so the man has to for instance I'll give
you the example here the man buys the
house because we we said that in our
examples yeah the man buys the house
here the woman makes it a home right
without the bricks and the roof and the
doors the bruh you can bring all the
decorations from Ikea or whatever but
there's no house Ralph
so really and truly that's the table
buff
all them all them little things are just
extras all the little mirrors and the
love hope live crap on the wall that's
just that's nothing bro that's nothing
really and truly you can live in an
empty house
you can feel protected in an empty house
you're you're sheltered from the weather
in an empty house the decorations don't
mean [__] they don't mean nothing like I
said I'm not talking just about the
Furnishings like just no but you said it
makes you mate the woman makes the home
yeah
it's just to me it doesn't just rely on
the furniture making a home is where
your kids come it's the energy that's in
there do you understand what I'm saying
it's where you feel like you're most
peaceful when you get home
do you know what I'm saying what was the
point like women make a man greater
so is that I feel like it was kind that
every successful man he's a successor is
a strong woman I feel like a man can a
man that finds the right a man who finds
the right woman he lives there's loads
of men
no no but I I think men are just very
successful man is a bunch of women he's
[__] crazy
in the front everywhere and this is this
is coming from like my dad was very
loyal but like no I don't think so like
I just think that men are great like the
the men that are gonna be great and
gonna be ultra productive are gonna do
that regardless of if there's a girl
there or not I don't think the girl
really does [__] I just think those guys
are Workaholics they're usually very
conscientious they're on their path you
can either come or you can go that's it
I think men are literally designed to
succeed with or without women because
they're meant to be building buildings
and stuff do they really need a woman
okay now I'm gonna if we fundamental
like to build a like whole civilization
and a society
usually they they get their skills and
everything and they're succeeding it's
the woman is like
it's a an addition to that but he will
be consistent with his you know
greatness but I look at success in two
different things you keep speaking about
yo you've built loads of people things
that doesn't make you a good man no no I
I just said that as an example that
means that when you let my people yeah
that is a great thing building no no
it's a necessary but I said I don't
believe that that's that is the that
just you doing alone makes you there's
more there's more things to you today
that make you a great man that's what I
that's what I think as well anyway do
you know what I mean Auntie Jenny says
behind not in front or next to you women
are supposed to support the man not lead
help me not headache I agree as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible